este aniversario número 44 de la
revolución de la República islámica
lleva en un momento en que la sociedad
está tal vez más dividida que nunca Aquí
está llamado este sector de la población
que históricamente ha apoyado a la
Revolución por muchísimos motivos pero
también llegó en un momento y en un año
donde el país ha estado conmocionado por
esas protestas que comenzaron después de
la muerte fue asesinato para muchos
burda más a mi nivel supremo después de
meses de encarcelara personas que
participaron en esas protestas de más de
500 personas muertas y cuatro
prisioneros ejecutados ha hecho un
llamado a la población a llamarlos a la
unidad a decirles que no caigan en la
trampa del enemigo sin embargo este
mensaje tiene diferentes significados
tanto en estas protestas como en otros
lugares de Terán donde esta celebración
es más vista con tristeza que con